It's payday!
Put that check in the bank and get ready to party.
Now you can finally pay some overdue bills,...
...buy that gear you've been eyeing...
...and stock the refrigerator.
That is, until the end of the month when the next payday is still days away.
More bills are piling up.
The refrigerator is empty.
Checks are bouncing and you don't have money in the bank to put gas in the car.
Living paycheck to paycheck is tough,...
...but there is a system that will make sure you always have the cash you need.
It's called the envelope system.
Instead of depositing that check into your bank account,...
...cash that check and bring it home.
Make envelopes for every budget item you have...
...like gas, food, rent and so on.
Then put the appropriate amount of cash in each envelope.
When you want to buy something, only use cash from the correct envelope.
This makes it so you won't overspend in any one category,...
...and you always have money for things you need.